believe it or not an estimated 19.8
million americans have already voted in
next month's election
some states are flagging early ballots
if voters fill them out incorrectly and
those people are learning
how hard it can be to fix their ballot
and make it count
major garrett shows us now how new
pandemic related voting rules
and linked lawsuits have led to
questions over how these early votes
will be counted hasan akeem voted
absentee
in elizabeth city north carolina last
month or so he thought
right now i'm weaking the knees because
see like i'm wondering why
my ballot is not going through and uh
you know nobody's
like really telling me anything hakeem
learned from a friend
his absentee ballot had been rejected
because it lacked a witness signature as
state law requires
i asked for it back i can't get it back
so
now what do i do do i go ahead and vote
again
until this week procedures for remedying
missing witness signatures were tied up
in court
one of more than 300 lawsuits in 46
states regarding voting rules in a
pandemic
in texas and ohio there are challenges
to ballot drop boxes
in pennsylvania and wisconsin legal
battles over
mail ballot deadlines david becker is a
cbs news contributor
and election law expert changing the
rules late in the game even if they're
good changes
that can be really problematic for
voters voters need
certainty about what the rules are in
2006 the supreme court weighed in with
something called the purcell
doctrine which says election rules
should not be changed close to an
election
it does not however define how close is
too close
the voters need certainty republican tim
moore speaker of the house in north
carolina filed the witness signature
lawsuit
arguing the rule reduces fraud and
procedures shouldn't be changed so late
in the campaign season
whatever you start with those are the
rules you don't change the rules
midway through the game just this week a
federal judge
upheld the witness signature requirement
which meant hassan hakeem's absentee
ballot was invalid
my ballot got rejected so i'm here to
vote again in person this time so
yesterday
he headed to his local early voting
center to cast a new one
and did so successfully do you feel like
this election is more important than
other elections in your life
yes this one is more important than
anyone i haven't seen yet
by any measure hakeem wasn't attentive
you might even say tenacious voter he
was tracking the process throughout and
now he knows his vote is in
and it will be counted but all these
rule changes and lawsuits raise
questions about voter access and the
quality of voter education
in north carolina data shows that the
percentage of black absentee ballots
that have not been accepted
is nearly two and a half times higher
than white voters
mail-in ballots tony yeah we know that
first-time voters are often more likely
to make errors on those uh ballots as
well major very eye-opening report thank
you very much
you know all this is done to reduce
fraud but the issue is that there's no
evidence of widespread fraud in any
election according to the fbi going back
as far as the country's history
it's a good thing he was so tenacious
because to use major's word a lot of
people just say never mind yeah but the
fact that he kept at it wanting to know
and i'm glad we got to see that he
actually
got his vote in and yeah counts yeah
that was encouraging but
by the same time you let's not miss the
point it's disappointing you have to
work this hard to get your vote counted
yeah
you need your id to vote in america plus
eight hours plus
yeah check on it later